[Inaudible].
Marine Corps, veteran followed and harassed by Antifa,
just for trying to open a dialogue with these protesters in Portland,
their answer bylands hosts of the Rubin report.
Dave Rubin joins me now with reaction to that and more. All right, Dave,
thanks for being with us. Now, I understand that this gentleman,
for more than 50 nights, uh, Gabriel Johnson, a retired Marine,
48 years of age had been kept awake by the sound of the rioting and the
explosions taking place outside his window.
And after two months of living in fear, um,
he said that he decided to go out and he said,
at that point I had counted 82 explosions at night and thought somebody
has to do something.
So he decides that he wants to go out and start talking to people.
It didn't end well, what can you tell us about?
Yeah, well, there's so much interesting stuff here because you know,
everyone can sort of feel this split that we have in the country right now,
whether you want to call it Democrat versus Republican left, right.
Conservative, liberal, whatever it is.
But I think there's something that really underlies that,
which is people that are willing to talk and
challenge their beliefs and engage in and people who just believe they
are right, because they believe it. And that's good enough in and of itself and,
and the other people.
And I think we're seeing a lot of this and this is a really perverse example of
it because this poor guy was followed home and everything else.
And all he wanted to do was converse with these people. Um, I, you know,
what's happening here also is that the more that the progressive mayor
in Portland and Seattle Angeles and say more that they just
allow, uh, anyone want,
because we know they can attack federal buildings.
You can stop cars and streets. You can attack police officers.
You can light things on fire. I mean, the litany of things is endless.
The more they allow that to happen.
Well then what they're also saying is the line of what's acceptable.
We'll just keep moving. So why not follow someone home?
Why not attack someone in a restaurant or attack their car or, or,
or whatever else you want to do. And I think what,
what falls beneath that really is just that we are,
if we're going to remain in a civil society, which I certainly hope we are,
and I know you'd like to, and all your viewers want us to,
we better start putting some lines in the sand and saying,
this is not going to be tolerable anymore.
And I think Trump's basically trying to do that,
which is why he's bringing in the feds because these guys just won't do anything
in their own cities.
But, but, but, but they've just so, you know, I mean the fence, I mean,
we're not talking about a whole lot of them, you know,
it's just a fence to watch the federal courthouse. You know,
they have an obligation, they should they're required.
And then in all of these joint task, but you know,
the truth is that since there's the so-called bail reform,
they let these guys out. As soon as the police make the paperwork,
that's assuming the police make an arrest. I mean, anarchy is here,
Dave. And my concern is if they're following this guy,
a Marine Corps vet home, what's the next step.
Okay. There's no police to enforce the law.
And what if they don't like what he said? What about this guy, uh,
who was shot in the head? Uh,
because he had all of these pro-Trump signs in front of his business.
Now they're,
they're thinking that that murder may have been politically motivated.
Well, this was the danger that I was warning about for about five years on my
show. Because if you call everybody a Nazi,
if all of your political opponents are Nazis and white supremacists and bigots
and racists and homophobes, the worst things that we can come up with, well,
then it won't just be enough to, to defeat them in the battle of ideas.
Of course violence will be okay.
And now the bizarre part here is that these same people, uh,
who seemingly are for violence are not seemingly. We know they're for violent.
They also will tell you words are violent.
So certain words apparently are too dangerous to them, but then violence.
That really is the, the danger of this entire movement.
It's not based in something that we can build the society, right?
If you want to talk about any of the issues that they want to talk about,
whatever they believe, okay.
See all sorts of people across the political spectrum that will talk to you. Uh,
but if your answer is we're going to, yeah, we're going to burn everything down.
People won't get it.
Dave. Alright, Dave Rubin, thanks for being with us tonight.
We'll be right back.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.